the hooded man is one of the strangest
mysteries in Game of Thrones in the
latest book the Bolton's have Winterfell
but Stannis Baratheon's army is coming
to attack them so the Bolton's rallied
their own army with a phrase and
northern allies crowding thousands of
soldiers into Winterfell and as a snow
storm falls tensions rise because these
northern houses say they support the
Bolton's but most of them actually hate
the Bolton's because the Bolton's and
frays betrayed the Starks and killed
hundreds of Northmen at the red wedding
the North remembers these Bolton crimes
so some northern Lords plan to betray
the Bolton's we know Wyman Manderly is
against the Bolton's and the umbers and
Dustin's might be too Ramsay marries a
girl who the Bolton's say is I a stock
though she's actually a girl called Jane
mance rayder
and seek swaddling women infiltrate
Winterfell to rescue this girl and Theon
Greyjoy wanders the castle like a ghost
broken by Ramsay's torture and all the
while Stannis and his army her camped in
the snow nearby so there's a lot going
on in Winterfell the Bolton Frey
Northern Alliance is dangerously
unstable the castle is full of plots
secrets and lies and a mysterious
murderer walks the castle at night one
morning they find a dead man in
Winterfell a Riz well soldier with a
broken neck half buried in the snow then
a dead Frey Squire is found naked in the
castle graveyard
and a dead Flint soldier in the stables
then one of Ramsay's friends is killed a
man called yellow dick his penis was cut
off and stuffed into his mouth so hard
that his teeth broke these murders get
everyone suspicious rumors fly and
tensions rise between the Northmen and
the phrase [ __ ] really hits the fan
after the 5th murder because this victim
isn't just some random soldier it's
little Walder Frey the 9 year old
grandson of Lord Walder Frey
the phrase accused women of the murder
and the phrase and manda Lee start
fighting so to stop his army destroying
itself Roose Bolton orders the phrase
and manda leaves to go out and attack
Stannis which is actually exactly what
Stannis wants Stannis seems to be
planning a trap for the phrase which is
explained in our pink letter video so
these Winterfell murders may be a
deliberate plan to create conflict in
Winterfell to lure the Bolton's into
Stannis's trap because these five murder
victims aren't random they seem very
deliberately targeted because most of
the houses in Winterfell hate the
Bolton's the only ones that seem
genuinely loyal to the Bolton's of the
phrase and the rizz Wells and those are
the houses that get murdered
Roger rizz wells groom a nice phrase
Squire and little Walder and Ramsay
Bolton's friend all these victims are
close to a lord who's loyal to the
Bolton's
except for this Flint soldier the Flint
sir of manor house and we don't know
much about them maybe this Flint guy
really was just kicked by a horse in the
stables and he wasn't murdered but
overall these murders seemed
deliberately targeted to piss off the
Bolton's and phrase to create conflict
to help Stannis beat the Bolton's so the
Lord's think the murderer must be
working for Stannis or working for Wyman
Manderly
some think that Theon is the killer but
they decided can't be Theon because he's
too weak in the books Ramsay's torture
destroys Theon's body he starved and
frail with missing fingers and toes and
he's psychologically broken he doesn't
have the strength to murder five men so
who is the killer
amidst the murders Theon wanders
Winterfell aimless and alone and one
night he sees a mysterious man in a
hooded cloak the man recognizes Theon
and calls him a turn cloak and a kin
Slayer many Northman hate Theon turn
cloak because Theon betrayed the Starks
and took Winterfell calling Theon a kin
Slayer is unusual but it's because
everyone thinks that Theon kill
bran and Rickon Stark who were Theon's
foster brothers so even though Theon and
the Starks weren't kin has in blood
relatives it's still kind of kin slain
the hooded man puts a hand on his dagger
as though he might attack Theon but when
Theon shows him his disfigured tortured
hands the man laughs and leaves Theon to
his fate
so Theon thinks this hooded man might be
the murderer in Winterfell why else
would he be striding around at night
with his cloak and dagger but the hooded
man might not be working alone there are
only three characters in the whole
series who called Theon a kin Slayer
first is the hooded man
then there's Rowan one of the wildlings
who helps Theon and Jane escape
Winterfell then there's crow food umber
Northman working for Stannis who rescues
Theon and Jane outside Winterfell so
it's very convenient that crow food just
happened to be outside Winterfell to
grab Theon right after Rowan helped him
escape so there's a theory that Rowan
and crow food are connected Rowan
really hates Theon for supposedly
killing bran and Rickon she spits in
Theon's face and says he wasn't punished
enough for killing the Starks
which is weird because Rowan is a
wildling the Starks and the wildlings
have been enemies for centuries yet
Rowan makes a respectful comment about
Lord Eddard's words why does this
wildling respect Ned Stark it's
mentioned that crow food umber once had
a daughter who was carried off by
wildlings thirty years ago so maybe
Rowan is that daughter
the umbers are loyal to the Starks so if
Rowan was raised as a number that would
explain why she respects Ned Stark and
why she hates Theon for killing Ned
Stark's sons and why she's willing to
risk her life to save the girl who she
thinks is Ned Stark's daughter
if Rowan is Crawford's daughter they
might have been working together on this
rescue and that's why crow food was
outside the walls at the right time and
the hooded man also seems connected
because the hooded man
peers on the same night that crow food
arrives outside Winterfell maybe they
came together and Crow food calls Theon
atone cloak and Kingslayer just like the
hooded man calls him a turn cloak and
Kingslayer
maybe the hooded man and Rowan and crow
food are all working together to rescue
aya and to murder soldiers to help
Stannis beat the Bolton's remember that
Rowan and the wildlings were sent to
Winterfell by Melisandre who works for
Stannis just like crow food works for
Stannis so how does the hooded man fit
in this conspiracy and who is the hooded
man one possibility is Robert Glover
the brother of Lord galbart Glover the
Glover brothers fought for braaap Stark
in his war but then Robert was screwed
over by Roose Bolton who sent Robert
into a trap at dusk and ale meanwhile
Robert's wife and children got captured
by Asha Greyjoy who still has his kids
as hostages on the Iron Islands in book
five Robert works with Wyman Manderly
in his secret plan to betray the
Bolton's and help Stannis so Roberts
already in an anti Bolton conspiracy
maybe he came with Wyman to Winterfell
and became the hooded man committing
these murders and maybe working with
crow food and Rowan when Robert plots
with Wyman Robert was a cloak and uses a
dagger like the hooded man has a cloak
and dagger and it makes sense that the
hooded man really hates Theon tone cloak
cuz the Greyjoy invasion of the north
cost Robert his family and home so
Robert Glover fits he could be the
hooded man but there is a problem with
this theory because Robert Glover knows
that bran and Rickon are alive so if
Robert is the hooded man and he knows
Theon didn't kill the Starks why would
he call Theon kin slayer he could argue
that Theon is a kin slayer because he
got some Ironborn killed at moat Cailin
and there is a crazy theory that Theon
killed his own sons which we'll get to
but it doesn't make much sense for
Robert to call Theon Kinsler so who else
could be the
man Harwin was one of ned stark's guards
he used to help our John and Rob learn
to ride horses he's a trusted and loyal
servant of House Stark in book 1 Hoenn
was sent on a mission with barrack and
Thoros but they were attacked and the
group became the Brotherhood without
banners when I Amit's the Brotherhood
she reunites with Harwin and it's an
emotional moment with ayah and Harwin
reconnecting with their past lives at
Winterfell Holland's fond of iya and
protective of her but they split when
Isle eaves the Brotherhood in book four
horns in the Brotherhood group led by
Lady Stoneheart the resurrected corpse
of Catelyn Stark stone heart seems to be
searching for her daughter
are you questioning captives about her
and by now stone heart must have heard
the news that Arya has married Ramsay
Bolton
so maybe stone heart sent someone to
rescue aya and Harlan is the perfect man
for the job
he knows aya he knows Winterfell he's
loyal to the Starks so maybe Harwin went
to Winterfell and when he realized that
Ramsay's bride isn't really aya he could
have become the hooded man murdering
Bolton's getting involved with Rowan and
Wyman's conspiracies since Harwin knew
Theon and the Starks as they grew up
together it makes sense that Harwin
would see bran and Rickon as Theon's
brothers and so would hate Theon as a
kin Slayer an argument against Harlan is
that he and Theon knew each other for
years so why doesn't the on recognize
Harlan it's not like the hooded man's
hood covers his face because Theon and
the man come face-to-face and their eyes
meet then again
Theon fails to recognize his own sister
earlier mistaken identities are a theme
in his story and nya has trouble
recognizing Harlan because he's thinner
and got a new beard
so maybe Theon just doesn't recognize
Harlan so Hollen might be the hooded man
originally on a mission to save Arya and
now involved in murder and conspiracy in
Winterfell and unlike Robert Glover
hawin has an emotional connection to the
stock characters so he could be a more
meaningful reveal
if he's the hooded man another
possibility is Halla Smolin another
Winterfell guard he guards Catelyn Stark
during Rob's war in the south until
Catelyn
gets Ned Stark's bones she wants her
husband's bones to rest in the crypt at
Winterfell so she sends Howell to take
the bones north but as far as we know
he'll never arrives at Winterfell
the Catelyn thinks that how might have
been blocked off from the north at mert
Cailin in Winterfell Barbara Dustin
tells Theon that she's watching for
Ned's bones because she wants to
intercept them and feed them to her dogs
but Barbary hasn't found the bones
either so where is hell if he was
blocked at moat Cailin he could have
ended up in nearby gray water watch the
home of Howland Reed who happens to be
the one man alive who would know that
Jon Snow is the son of Prince Rhaegar
also last we saw Roberts brother
galbart he was sent to Howland Reed and
galbart knows about Robb Stark's will
that makes John King in the north
so how old could get involved in a whole
bunch of potential conspiracies and if
he did eventually make it to Winterfell
he'll could play the role of the hooded
man killing Bolton soldiers maybe
returning Ned's bones like how and how
knew Theon and the Starks as they grew
up so it makes sense that how would hate
Theon as a kins layer but howls
personality might be a problem he has a
loose tongue and tends to loudly state
the obvious so he doesn't sound like the
ideal person for a secret hood admission
but it's still possible that how is the
hooded man so he'll or Harwin or maybe
Robert Glover could all be the hooded
man some fans think that Brendan
blackfish or Benjen stark could be the
hooded man it could kind of be anyone
who loved the Starks and maybe that's
the point one of the themes in the story
is that even though the Starks are
defeated their legacy lives on the North
remembers Ned Stark's leadership and
that's why so many Northman still fight
and die in his name
and are trying to save his daughter
maybe the hooded man is the embodiment
of this loyalty living proof that the
North remembers he could be any unnamed
unknown Northman maybe it doesn't matter
who's under the hood but here's the
thing whoever the hooded man is he's
probably not the murderer in Winterfell
the wildlings are Jon Snow and
Melisandre sent mance and these women to
Winterfell
to rescue Jane who they think is aya but
even if Rowan is an umber there's no way
that all these wildlings would risk
their lives just to save are you stark
Jon thinks they must have some other
hidden plan in Winterfell which is
probably the plan to help Stannis beat
the Bolton's by murdering these soldiers
we know these wildling women can fight
they kill several guards while Theon and
Jane escape so Theon accuses the women
of these murders and Rowan says they
didn't kill little Walder but she kind
of admits that they did kill yellow dick
and the others in the escape we see the
women use their sexuality to get guards
in a vulnerable position so they can
kill them and they probably used the
same strategy on these murder victims
like yellow dick has his [ __ ] in his
mouth and this phrase Squire is found
naked the women must have lured these
men with sex before killing them that
explains most of these murders but what
about little Walder if the wildlings
didn't kill him who did there's a theory
that little Walder was killed by his
cousin big Walder a big Walder is just
nine years old but he's ambitious and
brutal he's always talking about the
line of succession in house Frey and how
he's determined to become lord of the
crossing and it sounds like he's willing
to kill for it
he talks casually about murdering other
frays and when little Walters body is
found
big Wolders gloves are caked with these
cousin's blood bloody hands are a
classic symbol of guilt so it seems
likely that big Walder killed little
Walder to move up the line of succession
the wildlings killed yellow dick and
there is well and the fray as part of
their conspiracy and this poor Flint
[ __ ] Owens probably just kicked by a
horse
murder mystery solved but if these are
the murderers what's the point of the
hooded man like he could just be helping
Rowan and Crow food or Wyman or
something but surely this mysterious
figure has some deeper meaning a Theon's
story in this book is about escaping his
identity as reek and becoming Theon
Greyjoy again reek is broken
he's weak and afraid and obedient to
Ramsay Theon is the man he used to be
proud and strong a Greyjoy Ramsay's
torture and control has forced him to
suppress his identity as Theon reek
thinks of Theon as a different person to
himself
Theon Greyjoy died and reek is a new man
born in Ramsay's dungeons while Theon
struggles with this identity crisis he's
also haunted by ghosts
Winterfell is full of ghosts for Theon
Greyjoy because Winterfell is where
Theon grew up with the Starks and it's
where he betrayed the Starks when he
took their Castle Theon killed Northman
and Ironborn here people who trusted him
and he says that ghosts are angry
Theon hears ghostly voices in the
godswood and he sees brand Starks face
in a weirwood tree so with all his guilt
and trauma
Theon is seeing [ __ ] he's hearing voices
he's haunted by ghosts he doesn't know
who he is in this crisis between Theon
and rake and it's during this crisis
that they on sees the hooded man he
comes face to face with his mysterious
figure
alone in the snow and oddly Theon is not
afraid there's a theory that this hooded
man is a ghost of vision or
hallucination in Theon's tortured mind
and a representation of his identity
crisis like maybe the hooded man is
the ghost of who Theon used to be
because the hooded man acts a lot like
Theon once did he's confident and
purposeful and kind of a dick because
the man laughs at Theon's disfigured
hand which is like how Theon used to
laugh at people like in the TV show
Theon kind of always was a sensitive sad
boy but in the books
Theon started as this confident smug
sometimes cruel young man he was known
for his sly smile and his mocking
contemptuous laugh just like the hooded
man laughs at Theon's misfortune also in
book two at the height of Theon's
confidence and pride he wore a hooded
cloak like the hooded man so maybe by
facing the hooded man reek faces the
ghost of Theon Greyjoy
as part of his journey from reek back to
Theon the ghost also represents his
guilt and self-hatred because the man is
hostile accusing Theon of his crimes
it's like the ghosts in Shakespeare in
Hamlet and Macbeth characters are
haunted by ghosts which represent the
characters inner conflicts guilts and
doubts the hooded man could also
represent death in a faith of the seven
the god of death appears as a hooded man
called the stranger this hooded man is a
stranger and he threatens Theon
but Theon defies him saying that gods
are not done with me Theon faces death
and tells him not today instead choosing
life as Theon and escaping Winterfell so
the hooded man is an important moment in
Theon's character arc from break to
Theon given the psychological turmoil
he's in and all the talk of ghosts it's
possible that the hooded man is some
vision or hallucination in Theon's mind
but there are problems with this theory
because the hooded man calls Theon a kin
Slayer but Theon thinks he's not a kin
Slayer because he didn't actually kill
bran and Rickon so if the hooded man is
just in Theon's mind why would he accuse
him
of a crime he didn't commit there's a
theory that Theon is a kin slayer after
all because in book - Theon fails to
find bran and Rickon
so instead Theon kills two other boys of
the same age and burns them and says
their bodies of bran and Rickon the
mother of these boys is a woman called
the Miller's wife and Theon mentions
that he had sex with her a couple times
so maybe one or both of the children
Theon killed are actually Theon sons in
book 2 yagura tells the story of a man
who unknowingly killed his own father
she says the gods hate kin Slayers even
when they kill unknowing if they'd on
unknowingly murdered his own children
it's similar to how he unknowingly tried
to have sex with his own sister there's
an oedipal Freudian thing going on here
maybe deep down Theon knows that the
kids were his and he suppresses this
deep dark secret to his subconscious not
wanting to believe his akin Slayer at
one point he tries not to remember
something about these boys there were
things too hurtful to remember maybe the
hooded man calling Theon kin Slayer is
the externalization of that suppressed
memory a subconscious specter of guilt
it's a cool theory but there's no much
evidence that the boy's a Theon sons and
you'd think that if that was true it
would have been revealed by the end of
the book when reek became Theon so may
be the real meaning of the kin Slayer
stuff is to explore the question of who
Theon's kin is with a Starks his family
or the Ironborn was Winterfell his home
did he betray the only people who really
loved him these are the questions at the
heart of Theon zark and that's probably
why this kin Slayer idea keeps coming up
but if Theon didn't slay his kin it
doesn't make sense for Theon's ghost to
call him kin Slayer
so who is the hooded man there's no one
answer the man could be Harwin or how
love me
be Robert Glover in some plot against
the Bolton's with rollin and crow food
and Stannis
but the murderers in Winterfell are
probably the wildlings and big Walder so
it's not clear what the hooded man does
the man could be a ghost or delusion but
that theory has problems too maybe we'll
find out in the next book maybe we'll
never know the truth but one thing is
certain when you're infiltrating a
castle you've got to protect your
privacy and security so you can wear a
hooded cloak or you can use Express VPN
if you don't have a VPN your browsing
history can be tracked by your ISP and
by governments and by companies selling
your data expressvpn encrypts your
internet connection to keep your data
private it also protects you from
hackers if you're using dodgy Wi-Fi at a
cafe and it lets you change your
browsing location so you can watch
youtube videos that are blocked in your
country or watch American Netflix from
anywhere in the world
we used expressvpn to watch wes world on
HBO now a VPN is also essential if you
torrent movies and TV shows legitimate
legal downloads only of course so find
out how you can get three months of
expressvpn for free by clicking the link
in the description thanks for watching
please like and subscribe and comment
below who you think the hooded man is
thanks to the artists their links are
below this video topic was chosen by our
patreon supporters thanks to patrons
tunak good Tereza blog Madrid Nick
hunter Joshua garage Eric Hilgendorf
Esther and Cheers